emergency declarations already infected
Alabama Florida and Louisiana in New
Orleans weaknesses in the city's pumping
system led to major flooding this summer
after heavy rain for the officials folks
the pumps can withstand this storm
Michelle Miller is outside one of the
city's largest pumping stations Michelle
good morning good morning this city
breathing a collective sigh of here we
go again at this pumping station three
of its 15 pumps are offline across the
city nine others still non operational
as officials try to bring those back up
to speed hoping to avoid a repeat of
what happened here back in August once
again we find ourselves in familiar
territory threatened by another storm
that's coming our way
taking no chances in the Big Easy Mayor
Mitch Landrieu declared a state of
emergency in New Orleans the city's
drainage is she was revealed during
flash flooding back on August 5th when a
storm drenched the city with eight to
ten inches of rain in one day the
problems included pumps and turbine
power stations not working and a
shortage of personnel of the sewage and
water board the agency that runs the
drainage system the city has a total of
120 pumps 19 of those pumps were not
operational during the August storm
seven of them are back online and 26
backup generators are also in place
starting Saturday at noon we'll have 140
pump operators and 42 support personnel
that will be activated they'll be
operating 24/7 the main concern of this
system remains storm surge some
low-lying areas of Louisiana have
already been ordered to evacuate
Louisiana Governor John bel Edwards has
activated 1300 National Guard troops
across the state including 15 assigned
to New Orleans to monitor those pumps
this is a storm not to be taken lightly
this is not an exercise and if if we get
exactly what's forecasted it's going to
be serious this system is slowing down
oil production in the Gulf 15 percent of
production offline that's about two
hundred and fifty four thousand barrels
of crude oil every single day
and some staff already being evacuated
from those oil platforms Gail Michelle
thank you